hey what is up guys I'm Kim PhD here
still here at Google i/o 2014 back with
some more coverage of the number one
most requested thing I saw on my Twitter
timeline mostly and that was of the Moto
360 smartwatch which I think we can all
agree is easily the best-looking thing
that was unveiled at the show so as I've
mentioned earlier there were three
smartwatches unveiled at Google i/o we
already saw Android wear and these were
the three SmartWatch is basically flag
shipping it we have the LG G watch as
we've already shown it's a square we
have the Samsung gear live haven't
showed that yet but I also have it in
store it's a square and then we have the
Moto 360 and that as we've shown now is
a circular SmartWatch it's the only
circular SmartWatch and for that reason
there are some things that are unique
about it but there's also something else
that's unique about the Moto 360 and
that's it's the only one that's not on
pre-order yet it's the only one that's
not finalized so really what we get to
play with here is the Android word demo
on what they say is finalized hardware
so Motorola is not talking about the
price they're not talking about the
specs the material is the battery life
we only can really look at the things
that have been shown which are like the
display resolution and the final
materials that it's made of but again
Merola did say this is finalized
hardware so everything that you're
seeing that I'm observing about the Moto
360 will be on the final retail version
once available later this summer so the
number one thing obviously that sets the
Moto 360 apart and that's why it has its
name is the circular design and we
notice it's a significantly thinner
bezel all around the circumference of
the device then the square watch as we
see with Samsung and LG and something
we've also noticed in a lot of these
renders at the bottom there is this bar
across the user interface it's not very
big but you'll notice it and that's
actually where the display drivers are
so if you talk to Motorola they'll tell
you that instead of putting a whole
bezel around the entire display that's
where all the display drivers are in the
bottom of the screen so soon as you put
on the Moto 360 and actually the first
thing you want to know is how does it
fit on your arm how does it look and I
got to say it does look very good and
it's super comfortable as you've
probably seen in a lot of other videos
so the number one thing I noticed when I
put it on is it's very light it's much
lighter weight than the LG G watch that
I've been rocking for the past day and I
got to say it's comfortable because of
the fact that it's a circle so when you
have this square watch you're actually
taking up a lot more room on your wrist
and you
a slightly larger display if I were to
measure it diagonally I'm sure it would
be larger than the square G watch but
you get that in a very compact form
factor thanks to those really thin
bezels there's also one button on the
right-hand side of the Moto 360 unlike
the lack of physical buttons on the G
watch and that's used to sleep or wake
the device and that's also your power on
and power off and also on the back they
wouldn't really tell me if it's wireless
charging but you can imagine here that
this is where it'll rest in a cradle to
charge that there's no microUSB port
there's also interchangeable bands now
I'm what role if doesn't recommend that
you exchange these bands but it is the
same size where you can actually go in
and change which band you use but the
the black version has this sort of black
metal band and the silver version has a
sort of a lighter grey band here but you
can tell that they're custom tailored
bands pretty high quality looking
material and I honestly probably
wouldn't want to change them anyway now
I don't know what it is about this Moto
360s display obviously it's a circle and
that's unique but there's something
about it that just looks a lot better
now it could be because of its beveled
edges all the way around the sides that
was definitely different from the square
watches it could be because maybe the
display is laminated to the glass it's
closer to the surface it definitely
looks a lot closer to the surface and
the square watches but it feels a lot
more natural like a genuine high-end
watch and I think that's the idea of the
circular design talking to this LG peeps
they were talking all about why they use
a square design because it's more
industrial and more durable but Motorola
seems more concerned about a premium
experience that feels more comfortable
and usable as a watch and trying to get
people who like high-end watches to like
a high-end SmartWatch but other than
that you can see basically the Moto 360
demos look very similar to the G watch
demos I showed you guys earlier because
it is in demo mode and really they're
just here to showcase the final hardware
alongside Android wear but I am very
excited for when this comes out later
this summer now like I said Motorola is
not telling us anything about the price
it could be anywhere between 200 and 400
dollars I'm assuming it'll be on the
higher end of that scale because it's a
more premium experience but I couldn't
tell you what exactly the price is gonna
be but either way that's been it thanks
for watching I hope you guys enjoyed and
I'll talk to you guys in the next video
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]